next we've got a little bit of wisdom
for the holiday season it comes from
writer allison darling at apartment
therapy so she learned it from her
sicilian grandmother when you throw a
dinner party she says save the cleanup
for the next day
her grandmother threw big saturday night
family dinners and she never lifted a
finger to clean until the morning she
says that parties are to be enjoyed
savor the moment
clean tomorrow and basically if you're
there and you're festering about dishes
it can break up the vibe
kind of kill the buzz on the party
and this feels very revelatory to me
what do you think rossi well i like the
idea of it you know but personally
at the end of a good party i got a
little buzz going on right and so i'd
much rather clean up a little drunk than
hung over the next day
because there's nothing like that
feeling when you wake up and you walk
out and the plates are in the kitchen
and they're crunchy and crusty and you
gotta scrub
the real thing i think is that you
should get friends who clean up before
they leave
and you do
you do that dance when you're like oh my
gosh just leave it don't do anything but
inside you're like oh my god please
finish everything because i don't want
to do it
you know does anyone remember uh clap of
hands the movie the big chill
yes
okay
so i remember seeing that at a really
young age and there's the famous like
dish cleaning scene to motown
um and they're all like
um handing off the sun's drawing the
next one's washing and they're all like
doing it in a line and they're getting
down to motown
and it made me literally think that like
washing dishes was the funnest thing
ever so i always had this really
wonderful feeling about cleaning up
after dinner
because of the big chill
but
i like this woman's mentality because
you get that kind of anxiety like i
should take up my plate i should stop
the festivities i should move on to the
sort of
cleanup mode and i think this
grandmother is saying like don't lose
your buzz don't lose your free flow keep
it going we'll handle it tomorrow i
guess i think there's beauty in that you
know savor the party clean up tomorrow
clap of hands who's for cleaning up the
next day
clap of hands
who says
that night
yeah i don't want to dread it all right
finally we've got an interesting
approach to a first date that i need
your take on okay new york post reports
a tick tock user may the 11 got asked
out by a friend and she said yes but the
day before the date he sent her a form
a digital google form that started with
you've agreed to go on a date with
graham the guy's name congratulations he
promised you a good time with your
preferences in mind and then he asked
her some questions
just look at this
he asked me what my name is i sure hoped
he knew that answer what style of date
i'd prefer
um dinner in a movie is what i chose
because that's just what we had already
discussed but you know these are some
good other options let me ask what kind
of food i liked i honestly i clicked all
of the options because i i'm not a very
good at picking food
okay yes she had to fill out a form and
then after the date he sent her an
optional exit interview
i kind of feel like this takes
all the romance out of it like we should
not come with user guides you know
figure me out one of the best things
about dating somebody is when they do
something and you go oh my god you
noticed i like it that way oh you didn't
keep the launcher on it because you know
i don't like cilantro i don't know i
don't hate it i hate it i want someone
to say to me like all right i got dinner
tonight don't don't worry just put on a
cute shirt and i'll pick you up at seven
that's what i want oh yeah well that's
nice yeah like take take the reins a
little bit don't make me check a box
okay clap of hands who wants someone to
be mysterious surprise you and just
handle it
i feel like everyone in this room just
clapped all right
clap of hands who wouldn't mind getting
a form and filling it out
you you clapped i'd like to ask you why
what is your name my name is hallie hi
holly hi why would we like why would we
not mind a form
i mean i'm a planner
i have preference maybe it's just that
i'm a strong preference person but i
think that's nice i don't know i like to
know
what to expect i guess
i i think like you like i i want to know
like can i wear my sweatpants or am i
supposed to take it up a notch like am i
bringing my backpack with like you know
provisions or is it like a little tiny
bag because we need to be footloose and
fancy free i don't mind it so sometimes
a little organization doesn't bother me
a little bit but hello
hello
i hear you this is too much like what
are you my realtor i don't need a
checklist you know just
take me out get to know me
well
i'm with you and i get you
[Music]